yeah I just took a look in like again my
party rival SUNY Marcus like you
don't let a crisis go to mid-on line
extension in Queens
now this town like many school
developments around state resulting
design condition cabinet in Philadelphia
in school where students are given one
lamppost and Ameri our Delta chooses to
study research reports very exciting for
them put it on once we find it I hope
you succeed nervous but I know now
there's no make by magnet I have still
the case right
by myself threatening my mental is
closed off working better than a diamond
he built me a very high-tech and
exciting news do still disorder together
let me just stress that it didn't
stretch my ankle abilities to get
confused by lucky enough my quest rated
movie men Lee is statement and using the
Delton from fifty a miracle to happen to
the suit and by knocking this cool new
exciting features pursuing them here in
2015 where it will be kissed
it has a cool fire online realm back
having some cool differences in aligning
beautiful work in society at the gamer
even inspire man is using the virtual
public health community center but a
five-time set all humans course stock in
juices of the unit so it only makes
sense that I earn self is Delman so
let's not forget about happiness for
exact bedtime he in time to licensed a
over the moon and acting is a new XPS 13
doing one through the difficulty to kid
right here trans people in hot iron
middle people is broke earlier for a
Connecticut difficulties right answer
that easier order but as a serious
action you today to make sure you check
it out and take the presentation sulking
packs and girls very incompletely of the
commedia who likes me
any place that only is slightly ugly
it's a real honor to be it and make sure
you rinse in water in fact quite easily
thanks very much
hey guys what's up so really awesome Tom
Holland explaining a little bit about
the MCU iron spider suit so he actually
explained a lot more than what's in this
clip so let's break it down the clip
itself is part of a del integration that
they hired him for but they also kick
money in for the movie like he talks
about happy Hogan Tony Stark using Dell
computers it's all product integration
for the movie but he actually talks
about the scene that they have that
seems like it's on their field trip to
the Washington Monument
when nedley's helps him hack into the
suit so they learn about all his
features before he tests it out in full
I always love it when they
recontextualize stuff that we've already
seen with new commentary like this like
normally you think this is them just
hanging out spider-man getting a little
stir-crazy wanting to be a hero but
there's so much more going on in this
scene
so they've teased a couple of the new
abilities that the suit has and speaking
of which there is a new round of the
Spider Man giveaway it's a twenty dollar
comiXology gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video but you probably
saw the promo they revealed a little
while ago that just highlighted a couple
of the suits new abilities
[Music]
we actually saw him use the holographic
display at the end of civil war when he
was looking at the spider light so from
the comics is just the spider life but
obviously in the MCU they changed it
just a little bit make it a little bit
cooler so it's just a holographic
readout of all kinds of information that
the suit is taking in so it has sensors
all over it so the only like tease a
little bit about what it can do in this
promo they're not going to reveal every
single thing before the movie comes out
the web fluid is another big one the two
different kinds that you actually see in
the trailer are when he's taking the
robbers down that's sort of like the
normal web fluid but then later when
he's trying to say that big fairy you
see the hard core web fluid so this is
really just the beginning I know a lot
of people are thinking that Tony might
take the suit away from him at some
point in the movie and then give it back
to him because at the beginning he says
you know the suits years to keep but
you're not an Avenger but then later in
the trailer you see him fighting the
vulture so it's hard to tell whether or
not that's a prologue to the events that
are happening in present day after Civil
War or is that something that happens
later in the film but if you're looking
for surprises they'll probably save you
no special stark tech surprises for big
action set pieces like this fairy save
now whether or not Iron Man comes to
help him out in this moment this is just
a test of his strength so he is one of
these strongest Avengers next people
like Thor the Hulk so he can actually do
a lot of this without all the extra
stark tech but it's the tech in the suit
that takes him that extra mile things
like the web wings which is also a comic
book classic will help him with the
vulture because now he can glide through
the air even when he's not in proximity
to things that he can't swing off of
that's his big weakness if you dropped
him out of an airplane at 30,000 feet
unless he could web himself up a
parachute he would be out of luck
which is why he does much better in
tight spaces like you find in New York
City amongst all those buildings they
don't really tell you in this footage
either but there's also this funny
implied thing where Tony Stark sort of
gives him the suit and pushes him out
the door like here you go kid good luck
figured out on your own so that's why he
has to turn to his friend Ned leaves I
know a lot of people are like hey wait a
minute Peter Parker is a scientist even
though he's
really young he's still very smart he
made that first suit all by himself he
made his own mechanical web-shooters
so he's actually really good but I think
what they're trying to convey with some
of that is that spider-man in high
school is building a team around him
whereas someone like Tony Stark
is a little more independent he does
have Pepper Potts but if you go back and
watch those old Iron Man movies he
mostly takes her for granted for the
first couple times and then eventually
he starts to acknowledge her
contribution which is one of the many
reasons why she's probably not around
anymore although there are actually
real-life reasons for that too like when
it's Paltrow just isn't necessary for
Captain America's Civil War like like
you don't need her you don't need Jane
Foster to sell movie tickets that's why
a lot of those extra characters don't
show up again in these big Avengers
films Claire stark tower is your baby
give yourself 12% the credit 12% an
argument can be made for 15 well % well
I beta to all the heavy lifting
literally I lifted the heavy thing and
sorry but the security snafu that was on
your my private elevator you mean our
elevator it was teeming with sweaty
workmen I'm going to pay for that
comment percentages in some subtle way
later on time not going to be that
subtle but the really cool thing is that
Avengers infinity war start shooting on
Monday
now all the actors don't all shoot their
scenes at the exact same time Tom
Holland will be promoting spider-man
homecoming for most of the spring so
he's not going to be around as much as
the other actors but the Russos you know
who are in charge of everything have
teas that you will have some upgrades
for the suit when he gets to infinity
war what does that mean though they're
probably not going to change the colors
that much it's really just the text that
you don't see that doesn't stick out
like you don't see the spider light you
don't see the different fluid you don't
see the web wings unless he actually
activates those so there'll be a lot of
things that you don't see unless he's
actually using them in the way that the
Iron Man armor as well as the war
machine armor have a lot of extra
abilities that you don't see unless they
actually activate them
war machine is probably the best example
of a suit with a lot of hidden features
but Iron Man always saves all the
coolest toys for himself but he's
seeing some of them on to spider-man so
the first movie will be a slow
introduction to that and then as their
relationship develops spider-man becomes
an official Avenger he'll get extra
little things to add to the suit that
will help him depending on the villains
that they pick usually the abilities
that the hero has or the special tech
that he gets has some critical function
that helps him defeat his villain like
the ability to AI pilot all of the
armors in Iron Man 3 or even the special
lasers in Iron Man 2 like the extra
powerful laser or the different energy
sources even the arc reactor itself I
don't think they'd ever put an actual
arc reactor in the spider-man suit but
would it not be badass if the spider
symbol lit up like it does in the comics
like it has to be powered by some energy
source so Stark has probably figured a
way out to use his arc technology in a
less visible way than in his Iron Man
suit so congratulations to the new
Spider Man giveaway winner desi Martinez
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video please leave
all your requests for Spider Man bonus
videos in the comments there is so much
spider-man stuff that we got to talk
about this year so next video will
probably be flash season 3 tomorrow
morning well you guys waited at the post
you can click here to learn all about
the Miles Morales movie this Sony and
Marvel are making and you can click here
for defenders behind the scenes coming
up really soon thank you so much for
watching everybody so I thought I'll see
you guys tonight